Bitte schön.
Okay.
Gut.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin auf die Station As Aston Arsene-Teti und würde gerne mit Ihnen an das Aufnahmegespräch führen,
bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich einige persönliche Daten herfragen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Olaf Holkamp.
Holkamp.
Herr Holkamp.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja, Olaf schreibt sich O, L, A, F, O, K, K, O, L, T, K, A, M, P, Holkamp.
Holkamp.
Wie heißen Sie, Herr Holkamp?
65.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. April 1958.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie es nun seit?
81 Kilo.
Was fühlt Sie uns, Herr Holkamp?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit gestern ganz starker Zahn im linken Unterschenkel und im Fuß.
Also linker Unterschenkel und Fuß habe ich ganz starker Schmerzen.
Ich kann gar nicht mehr richtig gehen oder auch nicht mehr drauf stehen.
Das muss ich jetzt untersuchen lassen bei Ihnen, woran das liegt.
Okay.
Sie sind langsam aufgetreten.
Sie sind langsam aufgetreten, aber dann wurden Sie dann ganz heftig.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Also seit gestern ist es ganz stark, ja.
Seit gestern ganz stark. Aber vorher natürlich haben Sie eine Beschwerden.
Ja, in den Wochen vorher, der Unterschenkel war auch schon mal weh,
wenn ich etwas gegangen bin.
Dann war das auch sehr schmerzhaft und dann musste ich immer anhalten und stoppen.
Und nach einer Zeit ging es dann wieder besser.
Das ist so seit vielleicht fünf Wochen.
Für Wochen.
Aber seit gestern ist es eben ganz, ganz, ist der Schmerz eben.
Haben Sie in Ihrem Baubau Bein Rötung schwollen oder andere?
Das Bein fühlt sich irgendwie, das Bein fühlt sich irgendwie so,
das sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
Das sieht irgendwie heller aus.
Ein bisschen heller als das andere Bein.
Hast du die Bein Rötung?
Hat die Bein Rötung oder?
Richtig gerötet nicht, aber hell.
Also das andere Bein sieht irgendwie dunkler aus.
Das normale Bein, wo ich keine Schmerzen habe,
das hat eine etwas andere Farbe, etwas dunklerer Farbe.
Okay, okay. Ich verstehe momentan.
Haben Sie Fieber bemerkt im Bein?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Ich trage dich mal, wenn ich dich auch.
Nein.
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Wenn jemand um das Bein rumgreift und rückt.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Einer Schmerz kann von null bis zehn.
Null kann ich schmerzen und zehn, was ich tanze.
Ich würde sagen, sieben bis acht.
Yok.
Haben Sie gigantische Mersen etwas genommen?
Ich habe in der Nacht Leute Paracetamol genommen, zwei Tabletten.
Das hat nicht viel verbessert, etwas vielleicht, aber nicht viel.
Ich denke 500 Milligramm, zwei Tabletten beiden haben Sie aufgenommen.
Ich glaube, das sind Tabletten für Erwachsenen.
Okay. Zwei Tabletten beiden haben Sie eingenommen.
Zwei Tabletten auf einmal, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie deswegen andere etwas machen, Kalt oder warme Flasche?
Ne, habe ich nicht probiert.
Irgendwie fühlt sich das Bein etwas kühler an, etwas kälter an?
Ja, okay.
Sie haben kühle Gefühle.
Zwei Fünf Wochen haben Sie erleblich werden.
Ich muss fragen, wenn Sie laufen, haben Sie ein bisschen ruhig bleiben?
Wie viel Meta laufen Sie?
Wenn der Schmerz anfängt, würde ich sagen 70 Meter, dann fängt es an zu schmerzen.
Und dann, wenn Sie ein bisschen ruhig bleiben, können Sie noch weiter laufen?
Genau. Ich muss dann mit anhalten oder mich irgendwo hinsetzen.
Und nach einem Minuten geht es dann wieder besser, dann kann ich wieder weiter gehen.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für dich, Merson?
Ja, wenn ich gehe, ne?
Wenn ich gehe, dann bin ich nicht dran.
Aber wie gesagt, seit gestern ist der Schmerz immer da.
Ich verstehe.
Wagen Sie früher, deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arzt?
Nein, deswegen nicht.
Die Schmerzen in der Zeit verschlechtert.
Ich verstehe richtig, ja.
Und Sie nehmen, nein, okay.
Gibt es Ihre Kranken? Nein.
Ich muss andere fragen.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder nach Schweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Kalten Schweiß bemerkt?
Nein, das wäre der Schmerz.
Leiden Sie unter Appetitlösigkeit? Nein.
Petite Simmel?
Immer gut, okay.
Haben Sie ...
Ist Ihnen Schwindel oder Schwarz vor den Augen?
Nein, ist mir nicht.
Haben Sie Gustav verloren?
Nein.
Und haben Sie ...
... Breschen oder Übelkeit?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Hab ich nicht gehabt.
Mhm.
Und ...
... haben Sie Probleme oder haben Sie ...
... Schlafprobleme, Schlafstörungen?
Hm, ich kann gut schlafen.
Ich muss in der Nacht regelmäßig einmal auf Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Meistens gegen drei Uhr.
Aber dann kann ich wieder gut einschlafen.
Ja.
Ähm ...
... trinken Sie viele Wasser oder ...
... Alkohol?
Alkohol, ich trinke ganz eine Flasche Bier.
Mal vielleicht einen Schnaps, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Mhm, ich verstehe.
Ja, nochmal, ich muss ...
... nochmal fragen.
Ähm ...
... haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Ich ...
... hatte vor einem Jahr hatte ich eine Darmspiegelung.
So vorhin ...
... da war alles in Ordnung.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Nachdem ich es nicht mehr habe,
... Muslime ...
... mit der Darmspiegelung kontrolliert.
Ja, ja.
Mhm, mhm.
Und ...
... haben Sie erst mal eine Klopfenote oder eine Atmung?
Nein.
Habe ich nicht.
Manchmal ...
... ich habe manchmal ...
... das heißt, ich habe eine chronische Bronchitis.
Ah ja.
Mhm.
Manchmal, gerade im Winter und Herbst,
ist es manchmal so, dass ich dann einige Wochen stark husten muss.
Ähm, aber zurzeit ist das nicht so.
Okay.
Mhm.
Ähm ...
Sie haben gesagt, chronische Bronchitis haben Sie ...
Äh ...
... haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Was verstehen Sie unter anderen Krankheiten?
Zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, Blutprochdruck.
Ach so, ja, doch hohen Blutdruck habe ich.
Das habe ich schon ...
... das habe ich schon länger bestimmt, schon seit 20 Jahren.
20 Jahre.
Mhm.
Ich nehme auch Medikamente ein.
Ähm ...
... und habe auch hohe Blutfette, hohe Skolesterien.
Mhm.
Auch hohe Harnsäure.
Und hatte auch schon zwei Gichtanfälle.
Die waren sehr schmerzhaft.
Ähm, ja.
Und da nehme ich auch Tabletten für ein.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich muss Schritt für Schritt fragen.
Sie haben chronische Bronchitis, seit wann haben Sie?
Grundliche Bronchitis?
Oh, ich schätze seit ...
... fünf Jahren, zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Aber ...
Ähm ...
... im Momentan Sie sind gut.
Und Sie haben Arterelipertul, Sie haben Bluthochdruck,
seit 20 Jahren.
Ja.
Und Sie haben ...
... Blutfette, Werte.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie ...
Oh, ich schätze seit ...
... zehn Jahren.
Zehn Jahre.
Mhm.
Und Sie haben andere Bischwerten gesagt,
aber ich kann nicht ...
... ich könnte nicht ganz verstanden.
Also ich habe auch ...
... ich habe auch hohe Harnsäure.
Harnsäure, Wert ist hoch.
Und deswegen habe ich zweimal schon einen Gichtanfall gehabt.
Gicht im Fuß, Entzündung im Fußgelenk.
Ich weiß.
Mhm.
Ähm, wir sagen im Mexikanisch gut.
Ja.
Okay.
Und ähm, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Ja, ich nehme einmal Kandisatana,
habe ich ja auf dem Zettel stehen, Kandisatana ...
Wie viel Milligramm?
16 Milligramm, nehme ich eine ...
... raus.
Dann nehme ich Simvastatin.
Ja.
10 Milligramm, eine Tablette, auch morgens.
Mhm.
Ich nehme noch Alupurinol.
Dahinter steht 300.
300.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Morgens.
Und die chronische Bronchitis ganz stark ist,
dann bekomme ich von meinem Arzt einen Spre.
Spre.
Da sind so zwei ...
... Werkstoffe drin.
Einmal ist da Cortison drin
und einmal irgendwas, was die Bronchen,
sagt er immer, aufweitet.
Größer Macht.
Ja.
Das nehme ich nicht immer.
Das nehme ich nur, wenn ich so eine Bronchitis stark habe.
Okay.
Wenn die attacken.
Mhm.
Wissen Sie die Medikamentestnamen?
Das heißt Vianin.
Vianin.
I-A-N-I-V-I-A-N-I.
Es ist in der Cortison
Bronchotilatato, ich glaube ja.
Zum Aufweiten.
Okay.
Ich hab nicht, wie das heißt.
Ja.
Zweimal am täglichen ...
Ja, das nehme ich dann zweimal am Tag,
danach muss ich immer den Mund ausspülen.
Okay.
Ja.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, mich wurde schon mal operiert.
Einmal, da war ich, glaube ich, 18 Jahre alt am Blindarm.
Und vor, glaube ich, 7 Jahren
wurde ich an der Bandscheibe operiert.
Da hatte ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall links.
Und das strahlte auch ins Bein aus, in den Fuß.
Und das musste dann operiert werden.
Ja, das war ungefähr vor 7 Jahren.
Sieben Jahre.
Vor 7 Jahren.
Vor 7.
Ja, die Verstehe.
Mhm.
Äh ...
In London, Bandscheibenvorfall.
Ja, der Schmerz strahlte da ins Bein aus,
der ist ja Schmerz.
Und das war in der Lendenwirbel,
so habe ich meine,
gern wie 5-tieren Lendenwirbel oder ...
da drunter, in dem Fall.
Mhm.
Ähm ...
Gab es eine Komplikation, äh, während ...
Danach habe ich, äh,
viel Bankenbymnastik bekommen und, ähm,
Übungen gemacht und das ist dann gut geworden.
Ja, ist gut, ist gut.
Mhm.
Ähm ...
Haben Sie äh, gegen etwas Allergien
oder um Verträglichkeit?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Mhm.
Ähm ...
Trafen Sie ...
Ja, ich rauche.
Ich rauche eh, jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Und das ganze ...
So viel.
Das ganze schon ziemlich lange, 45 Jahre.
5,40 Jahre lange
haben Sie, brauchen täglich
Einschätzungskarette.
Ja, es ist so viel.
Und äh, regelmäßig,
wenn die Kotinkonsum schadet Ihrer Gesundheit.
Ich werde Ihnen möglichst zu aufzuhören
oder zu redestieren, bitte.
Ja, also das sagt meine Familie,
das sagt mir mein Arzt.
Aber ich hab's bisher nicht geschafft.
Ja.
Äh, Herr, äh, Holkampf.
Ähm ...
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, wir haben eine Flasche Bier
und eben etwas auch manchmal einen Schnaps.
Aber nicht ...
Woherklich, aber ich erinnere mich.
Ja?
Unregelmäßig.
Mhm.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, es ist eine rote Frage.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein.
Mhm.
Äh, ich muss fragen,
gibt es in Ihrer Familie
wichtige Erkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich meine, ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter oder Geschwister?
Äh, mein Vater, der ist mit 80 Jahren verstorben
an einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Nein.
An einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Aha.
Mutter, die lebt, die ist 92 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch hohen Blutdruck
und hat ein schwaches Herz.
Inzwischen, also das arbeitet nicht mehr so gut
und sie hat auch Zucker.
Zucker.
Ja.
Ich verstehe.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist 62 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch hohen Blutdruck,
aber sonst geht es dem ganz gut.
Na, Blutdruck hat er, ja?
Ja.
Mhm.
Ähm ...
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin jetzt Ritna seit einem Jahr.
Ich habe vorher als Maurer gearbeitet, auf dem Bau.
Ich habe Häuser gebaut.
Vor ein Jahren?
Ja, ich gratuliere Sie Ihnen.
Äh, ja.
Ähm ...
Garten, Gartenarbeit.
Mhm.
Nee, Garten, als Maurer.
Maurer.
Der baut Häuser.
Okay.
Ja.
Mhm.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Zwei Kinder.
Mhm.
Die ...
Richtig gesund?
Ja.
Die eine Tochter hat eine Schildrüse,
Unterfunktion,
aber sie bekommt Medikament und damit ist das gut,
wenn sie nicht hält.
Ja.
Gut.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Mit meiner Frau.
Mhm.
Ähm ...
Äh, ist anderer Tochter gesund?
Ja.
Äh, Herr ...
Vollkampf.
Äh, ich möchte ähm ...
Sammeln Ihre Beschwerden.
Äh, weil äh ...
Ich ...
Ich wissen das, ich äh ...
Ganz richtig verstanden habe.
Okay?
Ja.
Äh, Sie haben äh ...
ungefähr fünf Wochen ähm ...
ähnlich aber leichtere Beschwerden,
dass Sie haben gestern plötsch aufgetreten
der linken Unterschenkelschmerzen.
Okay?
Äh, und äh ...
Gestern habe ich starke Schmerzen
im linken Unterschenkel und Fuß.
Und die Schmerzen ...
sind ähnlich aufgetreten seit fünf Wochen.
Okay.
Ungefähr, aber ...
aber schwächer, nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Okay.
Äh, aber gestern Abend ...
haben wir ...
wir haben ...
seit ...
okay.
Ja.
Eine Seite.
Deswegen äh ...
ein bisschen ...
Ja.
Ist es fertig?
Ja, fast fertig, aber ein Minute ...
Okay, ja, ja, ja.
Okay, äh ...
ich möchte ein bisschen Übung machen.
Ja, danke.
Äh, und äh ...
Sie haben äh ...
helle Beine.
Und äh ...
wenn Sie laufen möchten, äh ...
möchten Sie äh ...
laufen, äh ...
etwa äh ...
70 Meter und dann ...
äh ...
müssen Sie ein paar ...
ausstehen ...
ausstehen und dann ...
äh ...
nach dem äh ...
nach ein oder ...
zwei Minuten ...
äh ...
können Sie weiter ...
weiterführen.
Weiter machen, ja.
Nach 70, nach 70 ...
für 70 Metern ...
Strecke, Gehstrecke ...
muss ich ...
muss ich anhalten, weil ...
ja, so schmerzhaft, so schmerzt.
Einigen Minuten Pause ...
geht es besser,
so dass ich wieder etwas geben kann.
Mhm.
Gut.
Ja.
Und äh ...
Sie äh ...
Sie haben kein Fieber, kein Sterfrost ...
und äh ...
kein Atemnot,
Herstrasen oder andere Becher werden.
Äh ...
und ...
äh ...
ja ...
Sie ...
äh ...
Sie müssen ...
wegen Ihres äh ...
Becher werden.
Äh ...
Ein paar ...
bleiben ...
so uns ein paar ...
Ein paar ...
bei uns bleiben.
Äh ...
Ja, wir müssen äh ...
äh ...
Ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ja.
Und dann können wir weiter äh ...
sprechen.
Okay, das können wir gerne so machen.
Gut.
Dann haben Sie jetzt ein paar Minuten Zeit ...
die ...
Fachausdrücke ...
möglichst ...
zu übersetzen ...
oder die Medi ...
die Spagnientensprache ...
Medizin zu übersetzen.
Ja.
Und ...
haben Kollegen ...
andere Fragen ...
haben Sie bemerkt, ich ...
meine äh ...
etwas auffällig äh ...
also ich ...
das Bein ...
das linke Bein, was du schmerzt,
ist äh ...
glaube ich, sieht etwas heller aus.
Heller, aber Wunder ...
zum Beispiel ...
offener Wunder.
Wunder, keine Wunder.
Haben Sie vor Kurzem ...
eine langere Reise?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Nee.
Das Bein ist auch nicht geschwollen.
Äh ...
verschlüge ich mich,
die Schmerzen ...
bei der ...
Hochlagierung des Beins ...
das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Okay.
Haben Sie ...
die Beschwerden nur ...
bei ...
Bewegung oder auch ...
in Ruhe?
In Ruhe.
Und seit gestern ...
seit gestern habe ich die Schmerzen immer.
Ja.
Auch in Ruhe.
Ich ...
ich möchte mich gar nicht bewegen,
weil es dann wahrscheinlich noch mehr schmerzt.
Ich habe auch kein gutes Kraftgefühl mehr im Bein.
Das ist ...
da kann ich nicht auftreten.
Ähm ...
vorher war es so, dass die Schmerzen ...
bei Bewegung sich verschlimmerten.
Wenn ich gegangen bin oder so.
Äh ... diese Fragen ...
die folgende Frage nicht gefragt, aber ...
äh ...
müssen wir ...
ihm der ...
Prüfung ...
äh ...
Fragen, hatten Sie einen Unfall zum Beispiel?
Äh ...
äh ...
Bein ...
Nein, ich ...
habe früher mal Arbeitsunfälle gehabt ...
auf dem Bau.
Aber ...
nicht mit dem Bein.
Ich hatte mal Unfälle an der Schulter und am Arm.
Aber ...
am Bein ...
ich hatte auch zuletzt in letzter Zeit keinen Unfall.
Keinen Sturz.
Äh ...
Ist Ihnen ...
schuppige Haut ...
oder Haurausweil ...
am Schienbein ...
oder am Unterschenkel ...
aufgefallen?
Nein.
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ja.
Gibt es ...
in Ihrer Familie ...
Gefäße Erkrankungen?
Gefäß ...
was heißt eine Gefäßerkrankung?
Gefäß, ja.
Äh ...
deine Mutter ...
Herzi ...
deine Vater ...
Schlaganfall gestorben.
Okay, ja.
Ich habe ja eine Gefäße.
Ach, Blutgefäße.
Vater ist am Schlaganfall verstorben, ja.
Und mein Bruder hat hohen Blutdruck.
Ja.
Und bis gestern ...
könnten Sie nach Kurschenpause weitergehen?
Bis gestern ...
konnte ich noch ...
äh ...
gehen in diesen kurzen Strecken.
So 70 Meter ...
konnte ich immer gehen ...
und dann musste ich immer pausieren.
Ähm ...
aber ...
äh ... seit gestern geht das nicht mehr.
Äh ... können wir anfangen ...
äh ...
Brut ...
Brutal?
Oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, ich werde ...
Wir probieren das.
Ja.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Abend.
Äh ...
Brutal ist mein Name.
Und heute habe ich ...
äh ... einen ...
äh ... Patientin heißt Olaf ...
Holkampf.
Äh ... eine ...
eine Amneskische Brut durchgeführt.
Äh ...
er ist äh ...
65 Jahre alt.
Am ...
äh ... für SETA ...
abkühlt ...
1908 ...
äh ...
für sich ...
und ...
1 Meter 6 und 70 cm groß ...
und 81 kg ...
äh ...
81 kg schwer ...
Ja.
Äh ...
äh ...
er kam zu uns wegen ...
seit gestern 5 Jahren ...
der ...
langsam aufgetreten erschimmersen ...
in linke ...
unter den Schenkelbein ...
und ...
äh ... linke Fuß ...
äh ...
er berichtet äh ...
Füllgefühl und ...
Bläs ...
Bläseln im Bein ...
oder ...
Feldenbein ja ...
äh ...
hat ...
kein Fieber ...
kein ...
Schwellen bemerkt ...
äh ...
und ...
die Schmerzen ...
als ...
dumpf ...
und Intensität ...
liegt ...
beim ...
7 ...
bis 8 ...
von 10 ...
äh ...
außerdem berichtet äh ...
der Patient ...
dass ...
er seit ...
5 Wochen äh ...
aber ...
leichter beschwerden hat ...
äh ...
er lauft ...
ungefähr ...
äh ...
70 Meter ...
dann ...
äh ...
muss er ein paar Minuten aushalten ...
und dann ...
kann ...
er weitergehen ...
äh ...
und ...
er ...
äh ...
hat ...
kein Fieber, kein Stelfrost ...
kein Appetlösigkeit ...
äh ...
kein Problem ...
im Stuhl oder Schlagstorungen ...
äh ...
und ...
er ... äh ...
er geht nur einmal die Toilette ...
äh ...
und ...
einige ...
einige Nüpturi ...
Nüpturi ...
ja ...
er hat ...
Nüpturi einmal ...
äh ...
und ...
er äh ...
hat ...
äh ...
er hat ...
nein ...
äh ...
vor Erkrankungen ...
...
in ...
eine ...
Arterielle ...
und ...
...
äh ...
trage ich ...
ja ...
äh ...
Zeit ...
...
Zeit aus ...
äh ...
Chronische Brunschitis ...
Zeit ...
äh ...
fünf Jahre ...
Nein,
Er ist der Tone seit 20 Jahren,
Frönische Brunsche seit 5 Jahren
und Hyperl epidemie seit 10 Jahren bekannt.
Er hat auch eine Gist
und er hat 2-mal Attacke.
Es besteht eine Hyperurikämie.
Eine 2-malige Arthritisurica
Arthritisurica,
Gichtanfall
und eigentlich Gicht.
Arthritisurich erhöhter.
Arthritisurich, Apakafasche, okay.
Es besteht eine Hyperpädemie
und Hypercholesterin.
Die chronische Bronchitis kann man wahrscheinlich als COPD.
Ah, ja, okay. Ist meine Fehler.
Und an der Operationen sind eine Ossoziliterse wegen Utaschenkelfraktur oder?
Nein, es war eine Operation wegen eines Bandscheibenvorfalles.
Leider. Ja, eine Bandscheibe, eine Disksprolapsus OP.
Wahrscheinlich im Segment L5, S1, links.
Okay. Und er trafte ein Colour.
Noch eine Appendectomy. Im 18. Lebensjahr eine Appendectomy.
Eine Blindarmoperation, ne? Gibt es Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten?
Ja, natürlich. Er raucht viele Eko-Tienten, viele Sekarate täglich.
Und auch der Arterielehipertuni.
Und ich gebe ihm nicht so viel.
Und ja, ich denke, meine Verdacht auf...
Entschuldigung, ich würde kurz sagen, es besteht bei den Patienten
ein erhebliches Risikofil.
Im Sinne einer Arterielehipertuni, einer Hyperkordesterinämie,
einer Hyperurikämie und eines starken Nikotin-Akrusos über 45 Packages.
Und das macht eine hohe Risikokonstellation für Herzkreislauferkrankungen aus.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Familiengenäse und...
auch, ja, genau.
Familiengenäse, männische...
Mühlenanämie ist die familienanämie auffällig?
Ja, in der familienanämie ergab sie.
Der Vater hat leidet an...
Moment, wo ist...
Der Vater ist an Apoplex gestorben.
Ja, und die Mutter leidet...
Wie alt war der Vater, als er verstorben ist?
Mit 80 Jahren.
Der Vater ist mit 80 Jahren an einem Apoplex verstorben?
Ja, und die Mutter leidet an Arterielehipertuni,
Diabetesmilitus und er hat Neokartinfarkt.
Momentan, die Mutter...
Die Mutter hat eine Herzschwäche,
wahrscheinlich eine Herzinsuffizienz,
eine Neokartinsuffizienz, aber kein Neokartinfarkt.
Ah, ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, ist gut.
Der Bruder ist 62 Jahre alt und leidet an Arterielehipertuni.
Auch gibt es familiären Predispositionen.
Also es besteht sowohl im Bereich der persönlichen Risikofaktoren
bei den Patienten als auch im Bereich der Familienanalyse
eine erhebliche Risikokonstellation für eine Herzkreislaufverkrankung
oder ein Gefäßritiko.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtsdiagnose auf perifere,
arterielle Verschlusskrankheit im Bein.
Okay.
Tut mir leid, meine Verbindung ist sehr schlecht.
Ich höre sie ganz gut.
Wir hören Radian.
Ja, ich kann nicht hören.
Ich kann mich nicht hören, achso.
Ja, im Moment kann ich.
Okay.
Verdachtsdiagnose, wahrscheinlich akuter Gefäßverschluss
bei der Arterielehipertuni.
Ja.
Das proximalen Unterschenkel links bei PAVK.
Anästisch-Klaudikazio-Intermittenz bei den Patienten,
wie er das schildert, 70 Meter per Kette-Strecke.
Und es besteht eine erhebliche Risikokonstellation
im Sinne eines Medizinapososos und Hyperchorvestorinamin.
Ja, genau.
Gut, was ist das differenzial diagnostisch in Betracht?
Differenzial diagnostisch, eine Artitis urika.
Wie macht sich eine Artitis urika bemerkbar?
Meistens kleinere.
Die Artitis urika ist es ja meistens betroffen auf das Großzehengrundgelenk.
Ja, und die rote Farbe.
Und die Berührungsempfindlichkeit, das wäre die Artitis urika.
Die würde nicht unbedingt zu einem Unterschängelstärz machen.
Ja.
Ein Kältegefühl machen.
Das ist mehr ein Hitzegefühl, was die Patienten oft verspüren.
Momentan eher.
Denken Sie, eventuell hat es keine Differenzialdiagnose
im Bereich eines erneuten Bandscheiden-Krolapses.
Eine Lumboschalgie, die zwar so nicht typisch ist,
aber der Patient ist davor operiert.
Ist das kein Taupeisgefühl oder keine Ausstrahlung?
Nein, Ausstrahlung nicht.
Aber der Patient hat zumindest sagt, er hat starke Schmerzen im Bein.
Und er hat das Gefühl, ist nicht so ganz gut anders als in anderen Beinen.
Es ist nicht typisch, aber wenn wir Differenzialdiagnose
schon Bewegungen machen,
wollte man zumindest mal daran denken.
Aber in erster Linie ist wahrscheinlich eine akute Gefäßproblematik,
eine akute Gefäßverschrift,
die Ursache der Beschwerden des Patienten.
Gut.
Ich finde, Sie haben das versucht,
ausystematisch zu erfassen.
Ich habe Sie eigentlich gut verstanden.
Sie haben so ein bisschen gewechselt zwischen mehreren Zetteln,
habe ich den Eindruck.
Auf der einen Seite lag links ein Zettel,
auf der anderen Seite rechts ein Zettel.
Und dann haben Sie Notizen gemacht.
Am Ende hatten Sie Probleme, das wieder zusammenzufinden.
Ja, was ist das?
Die möglichst nur ein Blatt vor sich haben.
Und das systematische Fachfragen,
weil sonst kommen Sie nachher durcheinander
in der Vorstellung beim Oberkampf.
Ja, ja, ja, genau.
Da sollten Sie darauf achten.
Und Sie haben sich bemüht, die Fachsprache-Bedriffe anzuwenden.
Denken Sie dran, die chronische Brontitis,
wo ich als COPD zu bezeichne.
Ja, genau.
Und nicht, ja, als Urike.
Urikemi, ja, Urikemi.
Ja, Urikemi.
Und ja, sonst fand ich das gut.
Und Sie sagen ja, Sie machen das zum ersten Mal.
Und dafür haben Sie das, finde ich, gut gelöst.
Und das ist immer...
Aber es ist so typische, ja,
zum Beispiel, 70 Meter laufen und dann ein paar Minuten aushalten
und dann weiter gehen.
Sehr typische für mich.
Ja, ja, okay.
Wir nennen das ruhig in der Vorstellung.
Man kann sagen, es besteht eine Laudicatio-Symptomastik.
In Sinne einer freien G-Strecke von maximal 70 Metern.
Der Patient anhalten, da geht es nicht weiter, weil es so schmerzt.
Ja, ja.
Ich denke, denken Sie so an die vielen Zettel, machen Sie nur einen Zettel,
einen Blatt.
Da arbeiten Sie sich systematisch sozusagen runter.
Das ist, glaube ich, hilfreich für die Organisation.
Ja, danke.
Danke für Ihre Tipps.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, fragen Sie nach.
Auch den Patienten fragen.
Können Sie das bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Sie sprachen zum Beispiel, statt dem Brandschalbenvorfall
sagten Sie als meine Unterschenkelfraktur.
Das davon war nicht die Rede.
Das war dann interpretiert.
Ich bin sehr aufgeregt.
Das ist gut.